can be a parent that goes on a school
trip I've done it for my kids school the
best possible motivation I don't even
want to reflect on what the other
motivations could be do you want to hang
out with your kid we're going to Tiggy
Winkles fantastic best little animal
rescue center in the world why is it
rescues in any Wildlife I arrive there
you know to be one of the parents with
me a little sandwich and that there were
two school buses and I was gonna get on
the bus with my kid but they go oh no
you aren't allowed on the bus with your
kid why and I went oh because in the
event of a car crash you would
prioritize the rescue of your child over
the other children I was like well hold
on a minute we're in Carnage the
cabasa's crashed this death there's
Decay there's blood the horn and the
wheels are still spinning I'm sort of
blessedly survive this terrible terrible
Collision I'd step over them do I all
these little five-year-olds I'll grind
them out I'll grab that one's kidney for
later my connection to my children is
gonna play a part I don't think I would
then go the rest of the years that I'd
rescue as many as I possibly could
doesn't seem like a very good way to
proceed with a school trip if you ask me